well while our city continues to grow
and expand you know there are some older
areas that are getting new life yeah one
of the city's oldest neighborhoods it's
an example of how a reinvestment can
transform a neighborhood we're talking
about fremont east bianca holmen live
this morning downtown to share what
entrepreneurs think has been changing
and how the changes have gone over the
years hi bianca
hey good morning john good morning sheri
so ferguson's downtown is a perfect
example of the project enchiladas impact
spots like mothership coffee and small
businesses like deeply rooted call this
place home from renovated motels to new
neon signs east fremont street from las
vegas boulevard to 14th street has been
upgraded it's a change business owner
amber nicholson has seen over the years
she's lived here in las vegas for 18
years and she moved to the ferguson's
gather house last year with a few other
micro businesses like her own
i've seen like the growth there
and you know just it's becoming more of
like a local place for locals by locals
um and i love that so when they reached
out to me about the space it was just it
was just a no-brainer it just felt right
we live in las vegas and it's a tourist
town and you know we're used to the
strip and it doesn't feel like it's for
us and downtown feels like it's for us
and that feels great
so her business deeply root is a
holistic health collective nicholson
says the ferguson community is very
supportive encouraging and that is
especially important for small business
owners so a lot that has come here to
downtown las vegas if you haven't been
down here try to make the effort and
come on down and support local
businesses and people who are from las
vegas and wanting to see it grow and get
better each and every year back to you
all in the studio